depuis un an emmanuel roule en vélo
cargo un véhicule électrique qui a
remplacé sa voiture et lui permet
d'effectuer sans stress ces trajets
quotidiens
ces pratiques de pouvoir faire du vélo
en allant au au travail et puis parce
qu'effectivement sur un certain nombre
de trajets en ville mal vélo cargo ou le
vélo en tout cas est plus rapide que la
voiture notamment pour ce gars est une
des nombreuses alternatives que propose
david pour inviter les tourangeaux à
privilégier les transports doux et
laisser la voiture au garage
t'as ton brassée à droite se dire qu'il
faut que tu roules de ce côté-là août
ce collectif organise des animations
pour éveiller des plus petits au code de
la route à vélo toujours on sait que la
plupart des trajets qui sont effectués
en voiture sont sur des trajets courts
de moins de 1 km ou moins 3 km l'idée
c'est de montrer aux enfants que voilà
une ville apaisée comme on est là
aujourd'hui sans voitures ne peuvent
circulaire en vélo en toute sécurité
c'est la quatrième fois que la vie a
interdit toute circulation automobile
dans son hyper centre et le bilan est
plutôt mitigé selon la mairie l'objectif
du collectif et de faire changer les
mentalités n'a rien contre la voiture
systématiquement mais on est quand même
très opposés au fait d'être seul dans
une voiture et de prendre tout cet
espace pour se garer alors qu'on pourra
mettre dix vélos par exemple dans une
place de stationnement etc
donc je pense qu'il faut absolument
limiter l'usagé de la voiture la prendre
quand elle indispensable
une initiative qui pourrait être
renouvelée dès l'année prochaine mais
sous une forme différente